very much free of threats.
In the Pantanal, besides the GPS collars, we are using another technique:
camera traps.
This camera is equipped with a movement sensor
and it photographs animals when they walk in front of it.
So thanks to these amazing devices,
we have been able to gather precious information
about tapir reproduction and social organization
which are very important pieces of the puzzle
when you're trying to develop those conservation strategies.
And right now, 2015, we are expanding our work once again
to the Brazilian Cerrado,
the open grasslands and shrub forests in the central part of Brazil.
Today this region is the very epicenter of economic development in my country,
where natural habitat and wildlife populations
are rapidly being eradicated by several different threats,
including once again cattle ranching,
large sugarcane and soybean plantations,
poaching, roadkill, just to name a few.
And somehow, tapirs are still there,
which gives me a lot of hope.
But I have to say that starting this new program in the Cerrado
was a bit of a slap in the face.
When you drive around
and you find dead tapirs along the highways
and signs of tapirs wandering around in the middle of sugarcane plantations
where they shouldn't be,
and you talk to kids and they tell you that they know how tapir meat tastes
because their families poach and eat them,
it really breaks your heart.
The situation in the Cerrado made me realize --
it gave me the sense of urgency.
I am swimming against the tide.
It made me realize that despite two decades of hard work
trying to save these animals, we still have so much work to do
if we are to prevent them from disappearing.
We have to find ways to solve all these problems.
We really do, and you know what?
We really came to a point in the conservation world
where we have to think out of the box.
We'll have to be a lot more creative than we are right now.
And I told you, roadkill is a big problem for tapirs in the Cerrado,
so we just came up with the idea of putting reflective stickers
on the GPS collars we put on the tapirs.
These are the same stickers used on big trucks
to avoid collision.
Tapirs cross the highways after dark,
so the stickers will hopefully help drivers see this shining thing
crossing the highway,
and maybe they will slow down a little bit.
For now, this is just a crazy idea.
We don't know. We'll see if it will reduce the amount of tapir roadkill.
But the point is, maybe this is the kind of stuff that needs to be done.
And although I'm struggling with all these questions
in my mind right now,
I have a pact with tapirs.
I know in my heart
that tapir conservation is my cause.
This is my passion.
I am not alone.
I have this huge network of supporters behind me,
and there is no way I'm ever going to stop.
I will continue doing this, most probably for the rest of my life.
And I'll keep doing this for Patrícia, my namesake,
one of the first tapirs we captured and monitored in the Atlantic Forest
many, many years ago;
for Rita and her baby Vincent in the Pantanal.
And I'll keep doing this for Ted, a baby tapir we captured
in December last year also in the Pantanal.
And I will keep doing this
for the hundreds of tapirs that I've had the pleasure to meet
over the years
and the many others I know I will encounter in the future.
These animals deserve to be cared for.
They need me. They need us.
And you know? We human beings deserve to live in a world
where we can get out there and see and benefit from
not only tapirs
but all the other beautiful species,
now and in the future.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)